your stubata grape galbi ma sulewic mamma
capitania caldara
le di mafia well
give me your heart there was a bonfire
give me a gun I will support
it my prayer when evening falls
when the crowd cheers me and I no longer know
how it was no fame but led to  to be
famous my father i can't see him
asked me for a photo my story and sad
but it made me a man and i dine my story of
rubies collided
at 3 when whiting presents as a
basket the femi of kinisia giving a
judgment in italy it was supposed art  of
then amount of months not to be
quite peaceful calm we tend to be
all right interest come
on
it's a difficult moment there I don't want to
remember the things that are that moment
some are sick that moment onwards
we have been there homeless being happy
smiling
[  Music]
the neighborhood is reborn holding a little
summer between patrols that tears up all
flashes but my mother with me in the gary has
never lived in a suburb
and has gone
I thought if it is not a hit.  in mine there
are few zombies
you know I am story between store in store they make their
debut
[Music]
you want to get me out it won't be easy to
sprinkle with salt like in carthage these
goliaths against david
true loves by the people sea my
preferences
you understand